[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
DAVE RUDDEN: Thank you.
Hi.
I'm Dave.
And I write books.
I'm still not used
to saying that.
I have sort of a
delighted, child thrill
that I'm somehow
allowed in the room--
not this room, although frankly,
that's also quite surprising--
but the room of being a writer.
I used to think you had to
be allowed to be a writer.
And you don't.
There's no passports.
There's no cancel.
There's no Grand High Poobah.
Don't tell John Banville.
He'd be really upset.
People like to make writing
into a mystical process.
When I say people,
I mean writers.
Because it's good business sense
to make what you can do seem
like a thing only you can do.
And writers need mysticism,
because without that, we're
just people with bad
internet histories
who talk to themselves.
I am against
mysticism, generally.
Teaching and writing for kids
kind of knocks that out of you.
You can be in the middle
of a huge dramatic talk
about creativity
and inspiration,
and a kid will just
put up their hand
and go, what does
the word indeed mean?
And you're like,
what does it mean?
I was doing an event once where
all the kids had read the book.
And so there was 125 kids.
They had loads of really
in-depth questions.
And I said, look, we're
coming to the end.
We only have a little
bit of time left.
I want your best question.
It has to be really good.
And like a crossbow, this kid
was like, I've got a question.
And I was like, OK, this
has to be really good now.
It's like our final question.
He's like, oh, I know.
And I was like,
all right, give it
to me, your best,
your best question.
What is it?
And he was like, what's
your favorite number?
And I was like, seven.
Goodnight, everybody.
So specifics-- I teach a
lot of writing classes.
And the first
question I get asked
is, how do you become a writer?
No, that's a lie.
The first question I get
asked is, why is your beard
so magnificent?
Beard oil and a tiny comb--
it's true.
But the second question
I get asked is,
how do you become a writer?
And it's quite a tough
question to answer,
because I'm an authority to the
edge of my skin and no further.
I know how I ended up
being a 29-year-old man who
spends most of the day
in his pajamas googling
throwing knives.
But the problem with writing
and with arts jobs in general
is that there's no blueprint.
Writing courses, daily prompt
challenges, retreats, groups,
masters, living in
a driftwood cave,
and writing poems on your
feet with the tears of fish--
there seems to be a lot
of different paths to it.
And this is a facet of
publishing, as well.
Bad books do well.
Good books fail.
Writers go unnoticed for
years and then suddenly become
stratospheric.
Suzanne Collins's
book "The Hunger
Games" was her seventh novel.
She used to write for
"Clarissa Explains It All."
I would watch that crossover.
I went to a talk with Brendan
Barrington at Penguin Ireland.
And somebody asked-- because
somebody always asks--
what's the next big trend?
What's the next big thing?
And Brendan gave
the weariest sigh
I've ever heard from a
human mouth, and went,
if you would have
told me two years ago
that a best-selling book in the
world would be BDSM erotica,
I'd a laughed in your face.
There is no blueprint.
And this does sound daunting
and terrible and all up
to kind of the
whims of the gods,
but that's no help to anybody.
And I really believe that if you
chart careers across the board
and go on safari
into writing groups,
and if read between the lines
and every listicle side notes--
I hate the word listicle.
There's a word for
lists of things.
It's list.
But you begin to
realize that maybe it's
not answers that provide a
blueprint, but questions--
questions of process, of
editing, of submitting,
of motivation, of inspiration.
How many of you at any
point in your life,
on a long car journey or
maybe like walking home
from the shop, or whatever,
played a movie in your head?
Just imagine something
happening, OK?
Yeah, a few of you?
Hands up-- who would like
action figures or dolls or both?
And when you played
with them, were there
plotlines, like sagas of war
and betrayal and heartbreak,
with a rotating
cast of whatever it
was you got for
your last birthday,
the kind of cinematic crossover
that Marvel could only
dream of?
Yeah, that was my
childhood, as well.
There was a tree in the
field behind my house
that had a really good
fork about eight feet up,
and it had these
red berries that
were the perfect size for my
T. rex to use as grenades.
My T. rex was a grenadier.
And my dad-- this is
a picture of my dad.
He looks like a garden
gnome or Captain Birdseye.
But he would look around,
and he'd ask, where's David?
Oh, is he up in the tree again?
It's like, yes, forever.
I come from a tiny
village in Cavan.
There are more people in
this room than there are
in the village where I'm from.
And the only way to
stave off the boredom
was to play movies in my head.
Now, they weren't
terribly complicated.
Hero saves the world, gets the
girl, happens to be ginger.
But I never assoc-- so can
you all hear me at the back?
I'm just curious, because I
keep moving back from the thing.
Yeah, we're good?
Cool.
I never associated
this with writing,
because writing is a mystical
art only a few people can
do, right?
To be a writer,
you obviously have
to be either English
or dead, right?
No.
Posh people become writers.
Geniuses become writers.
People from Cavan who look
like sunburned broccoli
do not become writers.
They're more likely
to drop a rap album.
And there's a terrible
standardization
that happens I think
around secondary school.
I've done 210 school
events in the last year.
And the one thing
I've noticed is,
if you tell a 13-year-old
they can be a writer,
they drop their head, and
they sort of warble at you,
and they--
because at some point, they've
been told that being up a tree
is a weird place to be.
If you tell a 10-year-old
they can be a writer,
they're like, yeah, I know.
I'm writing a book.
We lose this, or
it's taken from us.
And it takes a lot of
work to get it back.
Kids are fierce, relentless
sponges of information,
because they lack
experience of the world.
They are not used to stuff.
Adults are used to stuff
and beaten down occasionally
by stuff, and they don't realize
that ideas are constantly
sleeting by them or
sleeting from them.
What exactly makes the writer is
kind of difficult to quantify,
because writing in itself
is quite contradictory.
On one side, you need the
fierce self-confidence
that you have a story
that needs to be told.
On the other side, you need to
think your story is terrible
and that you need to improve it.
On one side, you
need to understand
that every single
person in this room
is an intricate machine full
of a billion moving parts
that has a slightly different
perspective on the world
than the person beside them.
But you also need to
understand that everybody
is pretty much the same--
unique commonalities.
Let me show you what I mean.
I'm not just a bedraggled man
who wandered in off the street.
Well, I am, but I
also wrote a book.
So if you've got the book in
front of you-- which you all
do, which is amazing and
hilarious-- is page 73.
"The woman in white
was eating light bulbs.
Simon couldn't take
his eyes off her.
It was horrible.
She'd found a cupboard on the
third floor corridor about six
meters from the closet
in which Simon was hiding
and had begun rifling
through its contents.
Linens were experimentally
sniffed and then idly tossed
aside, forming lonely
snowdrifts on the floor.
A first aid kit had been
emptied out as well,
its contents
separated with a toe
and then methodically
stomped apart.
Now she was opening
boxes of light bulbs,
shaking their contents
out into her palm
and holding them up to her
face before closing her teeth
around their fragile domes.
Crunch.
"It had taken Simon a moment
to realize she wasn't looking
for anything in the cupboards.
She was just destroying
whatever was in there.
Why?
He didn't know.
There was no urgency
to her movements
and a strange look of
amusement creased her skin.
Unfortunately, that
meant there was
no indication of how long
she was going to stay there,
blocking the corridor and
Simon's only means of escape.
"It was pure luck she
hadn't caught him.
A sudden, unexplainable
feeling of dread
had made him seek refuge
in the broom closet,
cracking the door
open a hair just
in time to see her appear
at the top of the stairs.
Maybe he had heard her
without even realizing it.
Maybe he'd felt her
presence or the air
her movements displaced.
Maybe, maybe the animal
part of his brain
was taking over all of
that prehistoric instinct
and awareness you just didn't
use in the modern world.
Simon didn't know or care.
All that mattered was that
he hadn't been caught.
"Suddenly the woman's
head jerked to one side,
as if she smelled his relief.
She spat a dry clot of
glass out onto the floor
and closed the
cupboard door slowly,
listening hard for something.
Simon froze, taking
his hand off the door
so it settled back against the
frame, hiding her from view.
His heart pounded
louder and louder.
Stop, stop.
She'll hear it.
And the floor creaked as
she took a step towards him.
Don't panic.
"With the door closed,
the woman in white
was more of a
collection of sounds
than a physical presence,
sounds that Simon
had to assemble in
his head to figure out
where she was, a process that
was doing nothing for his heart
rate.
Periodic creaks, her steps--
she doesn't care about being
quiet, why would she?--
followed by a drawling,
rasping hiss, her breathing
roughened by glass,
and then a cascade
of stiff, mechanical pops
that Simon realized in horror
were her fingers
clenching and unclenching.
Had he not seen her
with his own two eyes,
he wouldn't have believed there
was a person out there at all,
just a machine,
gaunt and terrible,
bearing down upon him.
But more terrifying than
that, though, was the silence.
Silence meant he had no
idea where the woman was."
Can you all close your
eyes for a second?
Humor me.
"Creak, Hsss.
Silence.
Creak, Hsss.
Simon closed his eyes,
then opened them,
and cursed the sound of both.
Everything had become magnified.
His heartbeat was thunder,
his breathing a storm.
The moment stretched
maddeningly, and Simon became
convinced he could hear the
zzzzt of his nervous system,
the shhhhh of his sweating
skin, and finally, beneath it
all, the tick of the future
becoming the present one second
at a time.
Silence.
The door handle began to turn.
Simon felt his stomach go
concave, The thought of being
that close to the woman's hand.
Somehow, magically,
he didn't scream.
Most children would
have screamed by now.
He was sure of it.
Creak.
Maybe just a little scream.
It couldn't hurt."
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
Who here is afraid of spiders?
Hands up.
Yup, it makes total sense.
Why do you need that many legs?
They're up to something.
Who here is afraid of heights?
Yup, makes total sense.
Nobody likes falling off stuff.
And what about snakes?
Really?
But they're so cute.
Look at them there.
They're lovely.
I don't mind snakes that much.
I was at a party once with a
snake handler, which probably
tells you more than you need to
know about the kind of parties
I go to.
And there was a
woman walking around
with a snake on her
shoulders, and she
was letting people put
it on their shoulders.
And me, being an idiot,
was like, yeah, go on.
Give us a go with the snake.
So it's on my
shoulders, and it's
really big and really heavy and
feels like an alive handbag.
And its head is sort of
moving around like this.
And I turned to the snake
handler say, out of curiosity,
has this ever gone
horribly wrong?
And the snake handler
went, ha ha ha ha ha, yeah.
And I went, take it back.
And when I was a kid,
I got glass in my hand.
Did someone here ever have
glass in their hand before?
Yeah.
For those of you who haven't,
it's unpleasant experience.
I don't recommend it.
And my sister, who is a
couple of years older than me,
was like, oh, you know if
you get glass in your hand,
it works its way into
your bloodstream,
and it cuts you open from the
inside out, and then you die?
I was three.
It left a mark.
So ever since then, I
have had a morbid fear
of ever getting glass
in my hand, which
is why, when I wanted to
create a really awful villain,
I could think of nothing worse
than someone casually biting
into a light bulb.
Unique commonalities, things
that mean so much to you,
you kind of think they
might mean something
to somebody else.
If you visit
downtown Minneapolis,
right beside Skol Liquor
and a bowling alley
called Memory Lanes--
I love that-- there's a place
called Orfield Laboratories,
and the quietest room on earth.
In this fiberglass,
swaddled chamber,
you can hear your bones slipping
off each other when they move.
And Simon, in that scene,
is trying to be so quiet,
he can literally hear
his nervous system.
The thing about her knuckles
popping mechanically
comes from my
friend Michelle, who
is a primary school teacher.
And like all primary school
teachers, she's super sweet,
and she's super lovely, and
she's a black belt in Kenpo,
like all teachers.
And because Michelle has spent
so much of her life punching
stuff, she can now pop
each one of her knuckles
without touching them.
It is exactly halfway between
disgusting and awesome.
And on her first
day of teaching,
the kids were being a little
bit loud, a little bit rowdy.
So Michelle just walked
out in front of them
and popped each knuckle
without breaking eye contact.
It sounded like someone
racking a shotgun.
And all the kids went, oohhh.
Ideas come from everywhere.
I am, as you might
be able to tell,
quite an easily
delighted person.
I'm fascinated by people's
lives and their careers
and everything they get to
do that I won't get to do,
because I'm not that person.
I think adults take
too much for granted.
They get used to not
asking questions.
They get used to thinking
life is just life.
I meet a lot of people
who think they're
too boring to write books.
And nobody is too
boring to write a book.
I'll give you an example.
I have a friend called Cormick.
And Cormick is very
tall, and he's very shy,
and he does not know I
tell people this story,
so you're not
allowed to tell him.
Although he might after this.
And I've been trying
to get Cormick
to write a book for years,
because I think he's
a singular, singular person.
He thinks he's just
Cormick, because he's
been Cormick a very long time.
But I'll give you an example.
You guys can be the judge.
When Cormick was four, he went
to Disneyland with his parents.
And he went in the
Star Wars ride.
Any Star Wars fans here?
Me.
At the end of the
Star Wars ride,
you're greeted by Darth
Vader and two storm troopers.
Now, even if you're
not a Star Wars fan,
you're obviously familiar with
Darth Vader-- black cloak,
black helmet, argh,
argh, bad guy,
or has really about
asthma, one or the other.
I have really bad asthma, so
I'm allowed to make that joke.
Very important fact
about Darth Vader--
not a real person,
fictional character.
Cormick is four.
So when he sees the
dark lord of the Sith,
supreme commander of
all imperial armies,
come towards his family--
this story's completely true--
he turns to his
parents and goes, run!
Save yourselves.
And he charges Darth Vader.
It's completely true.
Now Cormick is
quite a tall child,
so when he head butts
Darth Vader in the crotch,
Darth Vader goes down.
And Cormick, not a man to
leave a job unfinished,
just starts stomping on his
neck, screaming at his parents,
why aren't you running?
Should Cormick write a book?
Everybody should write a book.
You don't even
need to be the only
four-year-old with a lifetime
ban from Disney World.
That's why Darth
Vader has neck armor.
It's because of Cormick.
How can you not be delighted
by something like that,
by being that guy?
And I know that there is this
mystical image of writers being
these people waiting
for inspiration,
like kids with their
tongues out under a tap.
But that's not how it is.
Creativity is just questioning
everything around you,
asking why or why
not, asking what if?
You can wait for an
idea to come to you,
or you can start
charting the space where
it should be, like an
astronomer charting
where a black hole is by looking
at the space between stars.
This is why reading
is so important.
It shows you what's
already out there
and what needs to
be out there still.
"Knights of the Borrowed
Dark" is about as an orphan
who discovers magic.
That idea has been done.
What But this is a story
that I wanted to tell,
because those are the
kind of books that I love.
So I had to ask
myself questions.
If I tell you my book is about
an orphan who discovers magic,
what's the next thing
you want to know?
Hands up.
AUDIENCE: Why is he an orphan?
DAVE RUDDEN: Why is
the kid an orphan?
What happened to his parents?
OK.
That's very important.
Generally-- this is
terrible-- generally,
writers make their kids orphans,
because if they had parents,
the parents would stop
them going places.
So it's kind of like,
get out of the way.
So yeah, why is
this kid an orphan?
Why is that important?
What else?
AUDIENCE: Does everyone
know about magic?
DAVE RUDDEN: Does
everyone know about magic,
or is it a secret
thing that's hidden?
OK, very good.
These things are
very, very different.
What else?
AUDIENCE: What kind of magic?
DAVE RUDDEN: What kind of magic?
Is it the ability to
shrink, to throw fire,
to make kittens vomit?
I don't know.
What else?
AUDIENCE: How common
is magic in that world?
DAVE RUDDEN: How
common is magic?
Who has it and who doesn't?
Haves and have nots-- very
important for conflict.
I had to ask myself
all of these questions.
"Knights of the Borrowed
Dark" comes from--
I watch a lot of horror films.
And if you've seen any
horror films at all,
you know there's that scene
where the main character is
being chased by the zombie
or the demon or the stalker,
or whatever, and
they run upstairs.
And you're like, why
did you run upstairs?
Have you never
seen a horror film?
And the exact same
thing happens in books
about kids who discover magic.
Someone shows off to a kid on
their birthday and says, hey,
would you like to join
our secret crusade?
It's super dangerous.
There's loads of monsters.
You'll probably die.
And the kid just goes,
yeah, sounds good.
And you're like,
that's not realistic.
These kids were
automatically brave.
That's what bothered me.
Who here is a brave person?
Yeah, one person will
put up their hand,
and everyone else
goes, yep, me too.
It's so funny doing that
in boys' schools and girls'
schools, because
boys do, look, I am.
And I go, are you sure?
And they're like, oh,
there's a followup question.
I don't know if
I'm a brave person.
I'd like to think I am.
I'd like to think,
if I had to stand up
for my friends or my family or
do the right thing, I would.
But I don't think you can
know until it's tested.
I have a cousin who is a
firefighter in New York.
And he's been in so
many fires that his arms
look like melted candle wax.
And I was like, how do
you keep doing this?
the first time, fair enough,
maybe you didn't know.
But how do you keep making--
how do you keep going in there?
And he says, it's a choice.
I make it in the morning,
and then I go to work.
The day I can't make
that choice, I stop.
And that, to me, is
so much more authentic
than someone who is just brave.
But the thing is
that's not a book.
That's barely a sentence.
So I had to ask questions.
Who is this kid?
Who are their friends?
Where does the magic come from?
And in doing so, that showed
me the blueprint for my story,
like the way you
study in college,
and you realize
that studying just
shows you what you
don't already know.
I should have turned the
page while I was talking.
To think I do this for a living.
And with writing,
there's always a duality.
There's always two things.
So on one side, you go outwards.
You look at what's being done,
and you try and do something.
You try and go further than
anyone else has gone before.
But on the other side, you go
inwards, because the one story
people can't tell is yours.
Sometimes you end up in
situations so ridiculous,
you know they should
go into a book.
The following story
is completely true.
I was walking to the
shop late one night,
because I really wanted crisps.
I don't think that's weird.
Crisps are important.
And on the way to the shop,
I had to go through a park.
Now, when I got into
the park, I stopped,
because on the far side of
the park, there was a guy.
And the guy was standing
there like this.
It was like, hmm.
Nope.
Hmm, hmm, I've seen this film.
I know how this goes.
And my worry was
made a lot worse,
because as soon as the guy saw
me, he went, you, come here.
You look like a smart person--
which, when you think about it,
is exactly the kind of thing
a zombie would say.
Um, I'm not going to lie.
I was torn.
Because on one side, I
really wanted crisps.
But on the other, I
didn't want to die.
But crisps won out,
as they so often do,
and I began to walk towards him.
Now, the closer I
got to him, the more
I realized that
everything possible
that could happen
to a man's face
had happened to this man's face.
He was a rough gentleman.
He was like, I've got--
walking like a velociraptor,
apparently--
I've got something I
want to run by you,
because you look
like a smart person.
OK.
You know the way the
world's a dangerous place?
I'm beginning to.
Well, what if me
and a bunch of lads
were to just go around keeping
people safe on the quiet like.
Now, we wouldn't ask a
soft lad like you to do it.
And I was like, all
right, fair enough.
And there's a word for it.
There's a word for it, I know.
I know there's a word for it.
And I like, uh,
oh, um, vigilante?
And he went, I knew you
were a smart person.
And I couldn't help myself.
I went, like Batman.
Uh-uh, wrong answer.
He leaned in so close, I could
see each individual scar.
And finally, he whispered,
I would be like Batman.
Then he gave me a hug.
So once I survived that, I
knew it had to go into a story
somewhere.
And I'm not talking about--
I'm not talking about
just writing out
bits of your own life.
But people do that.
And you can analyze a moment.
Ask yourself why
it stuck with you.
And even if all
you take from it is
a grin or a whisper
or an eyelash,
that is fuel for a story.
I'm going to do another scene
from "Knights of the Borrowed
Dark" now, page 154, which
was inspired by my encounter
with the Crisp gentleman.
And in this scene, my
protagonist, Denizen Hardwick,
has been asked to join the
Knights of the Borrowed Dark,
this secret organization
of men and women
who keep us safe from
extradimensional predators
called Tenebrous.
Now, the more the
Knights use their magic,
the more it slowly
turns them to iron,
because bravery is a choice.
Bravery carries a cost.
So obviously, they're not
going to force Denizen to join.
But they say, look, we
have to go face the breach.
We have to go face
the Tenebrous in
this little, small Irish town
in the middle of the night.
Come with us.
See if you can handle this job--
work experience.
Now, the fight does not
go well, and they tell
Denizen to run for his life.
So when this scene opens,
Denizen is running down
this dark country
road, and part of him
is feeling really, really bad
for leaving his friends behind.
But the other part of
him is really relieved,
because in the
battle, he was crap.
And that's when he
runs into a character
that you guys met earlier.
Oh no.
"They'll be all right.
They're warriors."
Sorry.
Maybe this is a bad idea.
If I keep moving back
and forth, does that
make things-- no, it's fine?
Cool.
"They'll be all right.
They're warriors.
This is what they do.
It didn't sound very
convincing, even
in the privacy of his own head.
I'd just-- I'd
just be in the way.
The lights of the
village appeared ahead,
a false dawn beckoning hope.
Now, I mean, now they don't
have to worry about me.
There was a woman standing
in the middle of the street.
The breach still infected
the street lights,
curbing their luminescence
to firefly glimmers trapped
in glass.
Her shadow arched
across the road,
huge and gaunt and
close enough to touch.
Hello, Denizen said awkwardly.
It was all he could
think of to say.
White lips curved in a smile.
Hello, Denizen repeated,
feeling a little silly.
Are you OK?
He trailed off as he took
in the woman's blank smile,
the way she stood with
one shoulder higher
than the other, body
stooped as if held
beneath the pinch of a
thumb and forefinger.
She didn't seem to understand
what he had just said.
Um, Miss?
The woman didn't respond,
hands digging in the pockets
of her white overcoat.
Eventually, she pulled
out a loose cigarette
and jammed it in the
fold of her smirk.
It hung there unlit.
Horror began to curl its way
through Denizen's stomach.
The woman looked like
she wasn't quite there,
as if something essential
had been taken from her.
Her hair was a
ragged, white cascade,
framing thin cheekbones
and colorless lips.
She took a staggering
step forward,
her cigarette
bobbing in the air.
[EXHALES]
He couldn't just leave her.
She was the first
person that he'd seen.
He should help her,
get her somewhere safe.
It wasn't exactly
fighting a Tenebrous,
but it was the
right thing to do.
Miss?
Miss, why don't
you come with me?
I know some people who
might be able to help you.
Miss?
The woman raised her head
in a series of slow jerks.
And Denizen suddenly realized
he'd made a huge mistake.
It was her eyes.
They were bright and pale
and normal, or at least
a fiend's guess at
what normal should be.
Grey's words from the park
suddenly came back to him.
They look wrong.
Even the really old Tenebrous
that try to look human,
it's the little things--
the face, the eyes.
She hadn't done a terrible
job, at least as far
as Denizen could see.
All the bits were there--
irises, eyelids, whites.
Any doll maker would be proud.
It's not like there
was a way to fake
the things that actually made
an eye human, like love or pity
or hope.
The cigarette fell away as
the woman's jaw clacked open,
baring a throat filled with
a mass of delicate clockwork,
a total of cogs and
gears and spindle wheels,
all wet and shining, oily black.
Her howl made the ground vibrate
and far off window shatter.
[GROWLS] The echoes took a
very long time to die away.
Oh, said Denizen,
in a small voice.
Right."
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
So there's this one issue with
the questioning philosophy.
Because asking questions is
wonderful, but once you do it,
it's hard to stop.
Certain questions
start after a while,
asking themselves,
questions like,
what if this isn't any good?
What if I'm wasting my time?
Why am I doing this to myself?
I started sending "Knights
of the Borrowed "Dark
out to agents on
November the 1st, 2013.
And I started getting answers.
No was the answer
that I got constantly.
And in the meantime, I
began to question the work.
I began to question myself.
But the one thing that I had
learned from writing the book
and from interrogating each idea
is that some answers give you
options, and some
answers are dead ends.
Taking no for an answer
means no is the answer.
If I wanted to change the answer
I was getting from agents,
I had to look at what
I was doing wrong.
I went through every single
line in the book, asking myself,
is this line the right one?
Is this plot point
the right one?
Why am I saying vicious?
Do I actually mean cruel?
Why am I saying cerulean
when I really mean cerise?
Mark Twain says
that the difference
between the right word
and the almost right word
is the difference between
lightning and a lightning bug.
And every word does
make a difference,
because, on average,
my agent would
get 300 submissions a week.
She reads the first line.
If it's good, she
reads the second line.
If she doesn't, she stops.
Who here has heard
the word grand before?
Yeah, really, really
common Irish phrase--
I wanted to set the
book in Ireland,
because everything
is set in London,
because London is really cool.
But each word
makes a difference.
So I used to live in Egypt, as
you can tell by my amazing tan,
running from shadow to shadow
like the vampire of Cairo.
There is such a thing as factor
80 That would stop a bullet.
But when I was over there,
the local librarian,
Mr. [? Gamile, ?] was like--
I was teaching there-- he said,
Mr. David, I have a question.
Every day you come in, and I ask
you how you are, and you say,
I am grand.
Yeah.
But I looked up the
word grand, and it
means large and majestic.
And I was like, well?
Yeah, body positively.
Also, we say right over here
when we mean OK-- right,
I'm going down the shop; right,
I'm going to do my homework.
They don't say that in Egypt.
So I used to go in to
school and go, right, kids.
And they'd all go--
it's like, no.
Every, every single
word makes a difference.
There's a line in
the first chapter
where one of my villains,
the man in the waistcoat,
is speaking.
And the man in the
waistcoat is gross.
Everything about him is gross.
Even his voice is gross.
"The words roll off his
tongue like cockroaches."
I was really proud of
that line until my friend
Graham pointed out that
cockroaches don't roll.
So it's like, the word
skittered from his tongue
like a cockroach-- better.
This is what you have to do.
When it came to writing of
their genders and ethnicities,
I gave my book to people
all those ethnicities,
and was like, tear
this book apart.
Make sure what I'm
writing is authentic.
These are experiences
I haven't lived.
Tell me what I'm doing wrong.
I edited, I interrogated,
I sent it out again--
25 agents, 25 nos.
And finally, Clare Wallace at
Darley Anderson took me on.
We worked on one
more draft together.
And then she asked
me, do you want
to know who I'm sending it to?
I was like, no, I'll freak out.
And she was like, OK, now,
this process could take weeks.
OK.
It could take months.
It might never--
OK, Clare, I get it.
Thank you.
So 13 days later,
on my birthday--
a fun fact about me, I was born
the day before Valentine's Day.
Had I been born six
hours later, my mother
swears she would have
called me Valentine.
I couldn't pull that off now.
I definitely
couldn't pull it off
as a 15-year-old in West Cavan.
But I was in a two-euro
shop on George's Street,
to give you any idea of
where I was financially,
with my girlfriend at the time.
And we were trying to decide
between the fancy one-euro soup
and the normal, dust-flavored
50 cent soup and a baguette.
And she was like,
Puffin want the book.
And I was like, right.
What do you think we should do?
And she was like, I
think we should say yes.
And I was like, OK,
get the one-euro soup.
And I really thought my
job was done at that point.
I thought, you plateau out,
the book comes out great.
And the first thing
my editor said to me
was, so we have some questions.
I was like, a-huh-huh-huh,
I'm so sick of this book.
Ben is lovely, when he
says he has questions,
what he means is
we have comments,
1,000s upon 1,000s of comments.
So we've got too many mentions
of the sound the car makes.
OK.
Repetition, avoid, repetition,
avoid, repetition, avoid.
This one is particularly
embarrassing.
It's October.
It was November in
the previous scene.
Ah, ah, I've
accidentally written
a book about time travel.
And the thing is we went through
six drafts with the book.
And the thing is that's fine.
Every event I've
done, every edit,
every argued over comma, all of
the rejections and the effort,
and all of the questions
and all the self-doubt,
really come down
to one question.
Are you going to be a writer?
If your answer is yes,
it simplifies things.
And I'm not being reductive.
Just because the
question is small
doesn't mean it's
not complicated.
But it is a guiding principle.
Neil Gaiman talks
about the mountain,
a list of things he wants
to achieve in his career.
Anything that brings you
closer to the mountain is good.
Anything that takes you away
from the mountain is bad.
So interrogate that idea,
finish that chapter,
apply to that agent, re-edit
your chapter, reapply
to the agents.
Do whatever it
takes to get there,
because you've decided
you're going to get there.
That's the blueprint.
That's your answer.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
So if you have any
questions about writing
or beards or crisps,
the only three things I
know anything about, shall we?
All right, cool.
AUDIENCE: So my [INAUDIBLE]
DAVE RUDDEN: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: And
telling [INAUDIBLE]
how normally your writing
process, how it goes overall.
I'm especially wondering it you
ever tried nonfiction novels,
if you experimented.
Do you ever use nonfiction in
place in building your fiction,
and how could you [INAUDIBLE]
DAVE RUDDEN: Oh that's a
really, really good question.
And so in terms of
working in nonfiction,
I'm a little bit
terrified by nonfiction,
because you're really
putting yourself on display.
I like hiding behind monsters
and things like that.
But people say, where do you
get your ideas for your work?
And it all just
comes from yourself.
So I wrote "Knights
of the Borrowed Dark"
at a time when all of the
villains that I saw in media
were really cool
and kind of sexy,
Tom Hiddleston, basically.
All the villains
were Tom Hiddleston,
and they all had cool
plans, that you could almost
identify with them.
And I wanted to do
something different.
Now, I was bullied really
badly when I was in school.
This is the product of years
of theater, not my upbringing.
And I was like, in order to
make it authentic, in order
to share something that--
in order to make something
authentic, I was like,
what scares me?
And what scares me
are bullies still,
like the idea that you can--
like we all have that dream
that someone will say something
horrible to you in school, and
you'll turn and go, yeah, well,
cool line, knowing that, even if
you did do that, the body would
just go, shut up.
And you'd be like,
oh OK, you win.
So my three villains are
called the Clockwork Three.
There's the man in
the waistcoat who
is every single cruel comment,
like every single person
shouting at you from a bus stop.
There's the woman in
white, who you met.
She was like brute force.
And then there's
the opening boy,
who's a hurt child, because
that's what bullies are.
And the sheer meanness
and pettiness of them
comes from my own
kind of experience.
And the cost, as well--
like I would have
went through very bad depression
in my first and second year
of college, basically,
once I got away from home.
But things still
followed me, and I
had an awful problem
with self-harm,
which I'm through now.
And writing replaced that.
And the great
thing about writing
is you can pour all your angst
out, and at the end of it,
you have art or possibly a job.
But that's reflected
in the cost,
where I'm not
ashamed of the fact
that my arms look like barcodes.
But it's a thing
that happened to me,
and it's part of who you are.
So the Knights, you
can tell a career
Knight, because they've got
iron blooming across their face.
They wear their
experiences on their skin.
So yeah, it all comes from--
I say I don't write nonfiction,
but there's lots of it there.
And I'm sort of
getting into it now.
I have to talk about
Terry Pratchett later,
which is the scariest thing in
the world, because I love him.
And I hope I don't get it wrong.
But, yes, yeah, cool.
With regards finding
your voice, I
was a Neil Gaiman
cover band for years.
I wrote in other
people's voices,
because I didn't
have any of my own.
And that took years.
I started writing
when I was 20, and I
think I attempted the
novel when I was 25.
And it was the first thing
I'd ever written in my voice.
So if you read the
book, it just sounds
like I'm talking to you,
for better or worse.
And it took me a
long time of practice
before I got the
basics of writing down,
before I stopped worrying about
trying to sound like a writer.
I was like, maybe if I just--
I tend to make people
laugh when I talk to them.
Maybe I should
just talk at that.
So it's sort of trial and error,
and writing around your voice
until eventually, you just start
writing your voice, basically.
Cool.
Good question, though.
KARL RYAN: I'll go
to another question.
I just have a question
for you, Dave.
You talked to me about
worldbuilding before.
And I think that's a
fascinating part of what you do.
And even you just
briefly said there,
the world that you've
created here for this series
might live on in other books.
Maybe just tell us a little bit
about the art of worldbuilding.
And I think you talked a
bit about asking questions.
But just how does
that work for you
as a writer in terms
of building worlds?
DAVE RUDDEN: Cool.
So every line or every
word you put down
is an opportunity to get
something across to the reader.
But you don't have that
much time, basically.
Like as I said, my agent
gets 300 submissions a week.
You need to hook people
from the very first line.
So I could give people an
encyclopedic background
to the Knights and their
history through Europe,
but that's not what my
audience want to read.
So in my first draft of
the book, I write long.
I pack in every detail, every
cool thing I thought of.
I really interrogate my concept.
So the idea of the
Knights turning to iron,
I go, OK, what is every
single possible permutation
or cool thematic
thing from that?
I mightn't use all of them,
but I need to know them.
So I write the first draft long.
I throw in everything
that I can think of.
And then, when I go
to the second draft,
I start paring it back and
going, what is actually needed
to be known in this scene?
Is this something I
can't wait till chapter
4, chapter 5, chapter 10?
So you're drip feeding your
reader, because you want them
to constantly turn the page.
In terms of worldbuilding, I
like magic that makes sense.
I know that's a
ridiculous thing to say.
But I think magic is this
great, cool thematic thing.
Like with science fiction,
I love science fiction,
but science fiction has to make
a sort of scientific sense.
Magic can make narrative sense.
And I love concepts that you get
lots of legs out of, basically.
Does anyone read "The Dresden
Files," by Jim Butcher?
They're a book about a
private eye in Chicago,
who is also a wizard.
And they're great.
And in the first
book, the way it's
explained why no one
knows about magic
is because magic and
technology don't work.
If you try and film magic,
your computer or your camera
fritzes out, or whatever.
And that could just be there.
I mean, that's in Harry Potter.
That's a common thing.
But he analyzes and
interrogates that one concept
and gets so much
emotional depth out of it.
So Harry Dresden is your
sort of typical gumshoe.
He's very all he has is
his word, is his balls,
and he don't break them
for anybody kind of thing.
So the fact that he can only
use stuff from the 1930s,
because it's not technologically
complicated enough,
and the fact he
can only eat-- he
eats basically the
same thing every day,
feeds into his character.
And then later on, he
can't go visit his friend
in the hospital, because all the
life support machines will die.
And it's like, you really just--
a good concept just
has legs, basically,
and you get plot out of it.
And then also, it helps
you figure out plot holes.
I had a kid ask me once,
the cast turning to iron,
is it like scar tissue?
And I was like,
what do you mean?
And he was like, well, if you
get scar tissue at a joint,
you have to work out,
otherwise, it will seize up.
And I was like, that is the
best thing I've ever heard.
So now, all the Knights, I
pop their knuckles and things
like that, just like
keep themselves limber.
So your worldbuilding
is a chance
to get across theme and
character to your reader.
It all has to be connected.
Like Denizen is an incredibly
repressed, neurotic, anxious
person.
And his magic is this
wellspring of fire that's
constantly seeking to get out.
But the more it
gets, the more it
shuts you off from the world.
So yeah, it's a thing basically.
KARL RYAN: Great.
There's a question over here.
Right there.
AUDIENCE: I was wondering
how you were coping with--
or rather, not now that you
are officially a writer,
but before you
were a writer, how
you were coping with the
discipline of writing
and fitting it in.
And was that an
easy thing for you?
Because you said it
replaced depression issues.
Or was it a struggle to
get the routine going
and get the actual work done?
DAVE RUDDEN: It is
a constant struggle.
The only reason I sound
in any way competent
is because I planned out what
I was going to say beforehand.
You talk about like. oh,
it was this lovely path,
and you got there.
And we're talking
about like, no, it
is a constant, constant battle.
And there's a writer
called Oisin McGann,
who's been around for 10 years.
And his wife is a librarian.
And she was driving me to a gig.
And I was like, yeah, I really
feel now that I've got book one
out of the way, I can really
start finding a routine.
And she's like,
yeah, Oisin's been
saying that for a decade, Dave.
Good luck.
It's really, really tough.
You have to write
around your job.
Because people need to live.
People need to pay bills.
What I see, with the benefit
of hindsight, what I do
is set yourself some
manageable goals.
You are not going to sit down
and write a novel in one day
if you haven't
written much before.
Set yourself writing 200
words 3 times a week.
Once you find that really
easy, move yourself up to 300
per session.
Treat it like courage to 5K,
which I will finish someday.
You train yourself.
Now, if I'm writing a
first draft, I sit down,
and I do 1,000 words
4 times a week.
Because 1,000 words is a scene.
It feels like-- it's a
half a chapter if you're
writing children's fiction.
And I don't try
and go beyond that,
because if I tried to sit down
and write 5,000 words in a day,
I would fail.
And then I would have
failure hanging over me,
and I would feel
bad the next day.
I generally stop myself just
as I'm getting really, really
excited, because it
means hit the next day
like a ton of bricks.
It's weird the games you have
to play with yourself when
you want to be a writer.
You have to not be
too hard on yourself,
but also be super
hard on yourself.
Because if you don't
write your book,
no one is going to write it.
Now, I have to write my books,
because otherwise, Puffin
will break my legs.
I made that joke on Tubridy, and
I got a phone call from them,
I mean, like, Dave, can
you not make jokes about us
breaking your legs?
And I was like, or you'll what?
[LAUGHTER]
But now, I have
deadlines, and now, I
have people I will let down.
So it makes it sort of
easier and more pressure.
Whereas when you
write your first book,
no one is going to
be hanging over you,
so you need to be
tough on yourself,
whether that means
reaching out to a community
and finding writing
groups or even
having just one or two friends
who are going to be like,
write that book.
You just need to get it done.
I will say as well, though,
you don't have to get it
right on the first try.
It's more important
to get a book finished
than it is for that book to
be perfect on the first draft.
I meet a lot of
people who've written
really good first
chapters and never
written chapter 2,
because they're obsessed
with making it perfect.
Whereas chapter 35 is going
to change your first chapter.
So it's better to get it down
so you can see what's good
and what needs to be changed.
So write the thing, basically.
It's super basic advice,
but yeah, get it done.
KARL RYAN: Is there
anymore questions?
We have one over there.
Here, let me get you--
AUDIENCE: I already
have a microphone.
Hi.
When you get edit after edit
from book doctors and editors
and publishing houses,
at what point do you say,
no, this isn't an
error, this is my style,
I'm going to keep this one?
Is it important to resist, or
do you take all the feedback?
DAVE RUDDEN: Generally, with--
like I'm quite lucky.
And generally, if you're
a professional editor,
you're good at what you do.
So like Ben, every edit,
his favorite phrase
is, let's discuss--
where basically he'll
say, I don't quite
get what you're saying.
Why don't you try
and explain it?
And I might have a
perfectly good reason
for that being there.
And he goes, well, I didn't
get it from the text.
Because when you're
writing your book,
you have it all in
the back of your head.
You know how everything works.
Whereas the reader is
only picking up what
you've put down on the page.
So 99% of the time,
they have been right.
When I handed in book one,
there was a chapter in it.
And it was probably
one of the best
chapters I've ever written.
And Ben, the first time I
met him, he was like, well,
look, your book isn't
out for two years,
so we don't have to talk about
the changes I want to make.
And I was like, huh, what kind
of changes do you want to make?
And he was like, we don't
need to talk about this now.
Ha ha ha.
And I was like,
yeah, ha ha ha ha ha,
what changes do
you want to make?
And he was like, well, I
think the main character
reads as a 13-year-old,
not a 15-year-old,
because there's
no love interest.
There's no even kind
of scent of that.
And I was like, yeah,
actually, that does make sense.
And he's like, oh, and
I think this character
should come in a bit earlier.
And I was like, yeah,
OK, that's quite good.
And he's like, oh, and I think
you should cut that chapter.
And I swear to God, the
temperature of the room
dropped 30 degrees.
And I was like, you
want me to what?
And he was like, it
doesn't fit the book.
It's a great 1,700
words, but it's--
what he said was-- like
straight to my heart--
it's an Empire
Strikes Back moment
in what should be a new hope.
And I was like, that's a
good way of describing it.
But I was I was raging
at him for like--
and my agent was like, we don't
need to talk about this now.
Actually, we can have a bit
of a chat about agents later.
They're really
good as go-betweens
and having the
awkward conversations
you don't want to.
But normally, they're right.
But generally, what
they'll say is--
they don't tell
you how to fix it.
They tell you, you're
not getting this
across to the reader.
Find a solution.
And often, the solution
you find will, obviously,
make the book better,
and be even more elegant.
Like they're just
signposting things
that you haven't thought of.
Because your book is your
baby, and you haven't like--
you think it's fantastic.
So there's only a few things
I've ever fought them on.
Like when it comes
to word choice,
there's a line in book one where
it's like, his eyes narrowed
like an uncle disappointed.
And they were like, you mean
like a disappointed uncle?
And I was like, no.
I specifically mean like
an uncle disappointed.
And they were like, OK.
And we had a moment when the
American edit had come out,
where the main character
drinks a lot of tea,
obviously, because
he's from [INAUDIBLE]..
And the editor, the American
editor, was like, hey,
we think it might be
more age appropriate
if you have him drinking cocoa.
And I was like, this is Ireland.
We drink tea.
We give to babies in Ireland.
Cocoa's for people with notions.
And they backed off.
And normally, they
will back off.
If you can make your case
strong enough to keep it,
they'll go, OK, you know
what you're talking about.
But generally, it's that
horrible thing where
they'll say, what about this?
And you're like, oh,
oh yeah, OK, cool.
I did fight them on book
two, because there's
the main character has two kni--
he gets two knives in book two,
because he's useless with one,
so he may as well
double up, dual wheeled!
And he's got them in sheaths
underneath his armpits.
And he's really pride because he
manages to-- will you hold this
for a second?
KARL RYAN: Yes, of course.
DAVE RUDDEN: He manages to
draw them both without hand
capitating himself.
I was delighted with that word.
And my editor was like, hand
capitate isn't a word, Dave.
And I was like, but
look at it, though.
It's so beautiful.
She was like, even
if it was a word,
it would be de-handitate,
because cap means head.
And I was like, please,
just gave me this one thing.
And she was like, fine.
So I got my hand capitate.
It is always a conversation.
They will never
force you, basically.
So you just talk it out.
It's very situational.
You just talk it out
with them and see.
So so far, it's been
fine, basically.
KARL RYAN: All right.
I think we have time for
maybe one last question,
and then we're out
of time, I'm afraid.
So right here.
DAVE RUDDEN: I'm happy to stick
around for a couple of minutes
afterwards if people want
to ask questions one on one.
KARL RYAN: Thanks, Dave.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So I always love to read--
the first line of a book
would introduces a writer.
And you saying Dave Rudden
enjoys [INAUDIBLE] adventure
and being cruel to fictional
children, how does,
as a children's
fiction writer, it
work to be cruel to
fictional children?
Has it ever gotten
you to any trouble
in the modern age,
where you write--
where you have helicopter
parents or social jerks
a warriors?
Did it ever get you to any kind
of, like, ooh, no, [INAUDIBLE]..
DAVE RUDDEN: Kids,
kids love that.
That's the one thing that
kids come to me as like,
you always say it's like being
cruel to fictional children.
It's like, yeah.
I like books with
angst and danger
and where people are on the
absolute edge of their nerves
the whole time.
And my bio, and
even the first line
of the book, which
is looking back
at how bad a mistake to fill
the orphanage with books,
was my mission statement.
Because I knew that
my agent or the 26
people who could be my agent
would look at the first line
first.
And I was like, this is
who I am as a person.
I want to write a book
that's kind of mean to kids,
because kids love that.
If you come turn around
to a 12-year-old, which
is who the book is for, and
you're like, how it going?
Look at you there.
They're like, I'm 12.
Whereas if you walk in and
go, what's wrong with you?
Why are you so small?
They love it.
They think it's great.
And there is a lot of precedent.
Lemony Snicket was
super successful.
Every big word I know I
know from Lemony Snicket,
like plateau or marmalade.
And I wanted a book that
pushed the envelope.
It's the first time
I've written for kids.
And I was like, an
editor will pull me back.
There's no swearing in the book.
Swearing is a thing you
can't do in kids' books.
Violence, you can get away with.
And romances, that
stuff is kind of fine.
And swearing is
pretty much a no.
So there were a
couple of lines I
had to take out of the book,
because it just wouldn't
work with that in them.
And I went on, going, I
want to write a book that's
dark and weird and obsessing.
And if kids have a
problem with this
or want to talk
about the themes,
I will talk about the themes.
Same with parents--
I've done
parent-teacher meetings.
I can be like,
what was the prob--
because what was the problem
your kid had with the book?
It's generally a problem the
parents have with the book.
And it's like,
well, this is why I
did it, and hope I'm charming
enough that they go, OK.
No, my books are mean to kids.
That's pretty much-- that's
my mission statement.
KARL RYAN: Well, listen,
I think we're out of time.
Dave, we should point out that
the second book, "The Forever
Court," is out next Friday?
DAVE RUDDEN: It's on sale
from the 31st of March.
And we're doing the launch
in Easons at 6 o'clock--
at Easons on O'Connell
Street, at 6 o'clock.
And it's being launched
by Eoin Colfer--
oh, be still, be
still my fanboy heart.
And you should come along.
There will be
Prosecco and sweets.
KARL RYAN: Definitely
come along.
Listen, huge round of applause.
Thanks to Dave.
[APPLAUSE]